oh my god what do you think Trisha we
are here at the rehearsal for the
heartbreak tour
yeah it's like really really good like
I'm not gonna lie like I'm usually
downplaying all my stuff but I think of
all the things I've done this is what I
put the most work into and it's like
literally the best it's like amazing you
know I like you know like it's
Brittany's out on to our butchers is
like it's the second best thing what can
we expect to see out on the heartbreak
boy lots of lots of dancing because why
I love dancing I feel like that's where
I'm like happiest and stuff and I feel
like it's just like a show show but
there's so much I get like lifted like
boys get naked we shoot out like we have
like food we have just like soap like we
have so much like a girls like a lot of
us a like all cuz I thought there were
some really cool things
boil the tea yeah but there's like a lot
like some things I'm like stuff like my
managers who they have a date and he was
just like oh I keep like it's checked
because I was like yeah so they like
classic songs there's a new song you can
like hug me oh you can't do that with
Britney you care about touch me all you
want
[Applause]
so let's break down that iconic music
video a little bit because it truly is
iconic there's a lot going on in it that
was the scene of you where you're in the
hospital and you're dancing yeah how
this a little bit about why you chose to
incorporate that because it has a lot of
meaning for you it has a lot of meaning
people got really mad which I didn't get
so I'm guessing I broke up with my
boyfriend this year I ended up in a
hospital and then I ended up literally
being a mental hospital so I went from a
hospital one night being strapped down
shot with a divan in my leg because I
try to run away to being in a mental
hospital for a 72-hour hold and and yeah
I wasn't looking at it crazy but like
now it's kind of one of those things
where I'm like I feel like it's actually
quite normal I tell people and they're
like yeah that's nothing to me - and
awesomes like whatever I needed a little
mental vacation and now I'm like better
like but I think instead people like
illness and that's just like no it's
like kind of just being like this is
normal like I'm kind of normalizing and
now so that's I thought my head when I
was in literally reliving my mom when I
was in the hustle I remember like my
ex-boyfriend was there like another guy
was there and I just remember I read I
felt a movie because literally like to
like please came and like dragged me
back to his stretcher in the middle the
hallway at your sign I was like oh my
god what is this like strapped down and
we recreated that would see sexy doctors
and some makeup in here and meet
fabulous well I think what's most iconic
is that you've had such an incredible
glow up lately I mean I saw that you
post on Instagram like this is like the
best week I've ever been that like I'm
maybe 170 which I haven't been in like
literally since I was like 16 years old
I was 220 in February of this year and
I'm just I don't really know how he
always that's like Holly look you lot
thought oh wait you know you always that
sound like I don't know just like being
happier being active and just kind of
like trying to eat better and yeah I
feel I feel great it's like more than
like I know people like wow 170 girl but
like they still think on the big but I'm
like no I'm so hot you know and it's
just yeah it's just mentally I feel
better yeah when you look in the kind of
see your own transformation do you even
like recognize how far you've come just
like the past year has I've been able to
be the process that about I think that
way I actually do the side-by-sides when
I practice because I think I look the
same where I feel the same and I was
like oh no even looking at like my like
glass relationship and like me in that
relationship I'm like oh my god like I
just saw a really sad trust I recently
reviewed a video of like someone put
accomplishment even x-play for together
and him like making fun of like my food
I eat and I could just see like how sad
I was in my eyes like I didn't realize
it at the time I was like oh we're gonna
oh girl right you know yeah so um yeah
I'm a different person I'm just like a
just happier feel freer and I can't eat
all then I guess I'm all without anyone
counting down okay
that's the team speaking of Jason
obviously where do things stand with you
guys now have you talked to him at all
you still just not on speaking terms
that asus continue to ignore me so let's
talk about them but I'm so like oh well
I get some views this could be your
clickbait you know just keep talking
about Jason like I do that all the time
like she watches it all and you know
what I think it is kind of my thing now
like I've always talked my ex-boyfriends
it just so happens like he's like on
lines I mean like you're obsessed with
him and I was like oh
he views you know what I mean I'm just
about that view life but ya know I mean
yeah see he hates my guts and he dropped
some stuff off and didn't tell me you
just kind of like left it at my door and
I feel like you're some and then some
nights I don't when I start drinking
sometimes I'm like oh yeah like you're a
mediocre penis or something you know
what I mean but I say it out of love
every day I'm just getting views and
just doing so much better without you
you're just like but I like what I do I
mean no I'm having sex again so that's
good that's good miles you have some
funny tweets about David I remember
spelling each other my like oh okay are
you in David oh okay terms are you still
just act like you don't so I keep
laughing it and I want to see a blogspot
member get real excited I like romic I
hate it and they get stolen control like
oh my god don't even use this oh my god
- you know what do you think I love
these I you will ever make peace with
David and Jason like what would happen
if you saw them in public and you went
like what you ever go up to them or
would you just avoid but think about
that because I think part of me is like
I'm nervous that's so cool but then part
of me would be like oh my god everything
and then part of me is like you what's
up cuz like I'm writing them
face-to-face
there's Dara they're like scared people
you know like once you have to have them
like out in a different setting they get
a little more they're not
confrontational but I now that you've
kind of gone through it been through all
the sadness are you just kind of like
the happiest you've been in a while yeah
I can say I am like I get lonely like I
like to cuddle and stuff like that but
you know what you do get body pillows
like for pregnant women I cuddle a
pillow at night and it's like just a
good you know what I mean and there's no
candy bar wrappers in my bed the next
morning and it's like really really nice
out yeah and they stink and like you
don't I mean no but I have like a lot of
men coming with me on tour that's why
I'm like Oh single Trish has all the men
you know you'll see a job like I told um
a choreographer Cedric I was like can I
just like crying on everybody's I'm I'm
gonna
[Music]